um
[Music]
it's exciting to see many of you join
today and i think that many of you are
probably wondering
what makes this program different or
special
in the
available programs online where you can
learn about bioinformatics you can learn
about data science
the reason why we developed this program
is specifically to go beyond training
and offer an opportunity to participate
in meaningful research now in today's
session we're going to address many of
the challenges that are associated with
research projects especially getting
those research projects completed in a
short amount of time because typically
they do take years
at the minimum
several months and so what i want to
talk to you today about are some of the
critical things that we've
distilled into this online program
and introduce you to some of the mentors
to talk about some of the specific
project examples but before we do that
let me briefly address some of these
critical points
one of the things that we've realized is
that when people join our different
training programs
their background in life sciences might
prevent them from
really getting deeper into
bioinformatics methods allowing them to
superficially know the terminology but
not really know how to apply it
practically so i uh think that you know
many of you will discover that some of
the training materials that we've
designed are specifically uh useful for
those that come from a life science
background without a lot of technical
engineering
skills and then you will be able to
really appreciate both the logic of the
analysis and technically how to become
independent and efficient in
bioinformatics analysis methods
the second area where many students
have faced a challenge is finding an
impactful research topic
and to find that impactful and
meaningful topic
we've addressed this through two
different
approaches the first one is literature
review how to perform literature review
so that you can find
the specific gaps in research and
opportunities for you to do something
new and different and at the same time
find data that you can find answers for
that question that research question so
it's developing the research question
finding the data we review many data
sets with our community to provide you
with a curated start so that you can
start investigating a topic using a
curated data set and then find
opportunities to innovate and ask
questions of these data sets including
introducing you to the
approach of finding data sets online
and then finally the third topic is how
to know that what you have developed is
a meaningful project not just for the
student community but also for the
scientific community and that's why we
have developed a network of mentors that
come from a research as well as industry
background that are able to provide you
with
critical feedback so that your project
becomes more impactful and refine the
project or provide you with suggestions
on how to refine the project to make it
more impactful and
essentially providing with more
visibility and feedback
so before we continue i want to show you
how some of these things are going to
actually take place
and i want to introduce you to some of
the program resources really briefly and
to do that i want to point you to
two servers and and two portals one of
them is going to be the server t-bio
info portal this is going to be a portal
that is
designed to provide you with an
opportunity to process big data
and also the learn omixlogic
portal where you will find all the
training resources so let's first go to
this portal the omixlogic portal and
thank you adjust before sharing that
link and i'll also explain how those two
things are linked
so if you go to this portal link
you will find here i think a very clear
explanation of what this portal really
is the omixlogic portal is designed to
provide you with everything to get you
started and get you into these real
world practical challenges with big data
and you will find here tutorials project
examples on how to run various pipelines
and apply different analytical methods
you will find here different types of
research projects that you can get
started with in the fields of oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience
agriculture and others and you will also
find meaningful application of your
logic how do you understand that you can
take raw data and get structured data
that you can analyze and supplement that
with training with coding and machine
learning and data science and analytics
all of the necessary skills that will
make you independent and self-sufficient
as you go forward with your projects
so the first thing that you want to do
is you want to click right here on login
and i will give you a couple of minutes
to complete your registration
so once you click on login you have the
option here to create an account
okay so i will wait a few minutes for
those of you that don't have an account
please take a few moments right now to
fill in your name your email and create
a password it's a free account you don't
have to pay for this but you will
immediately get access to some of the
free resources that are made available
and hopefully they will inspire you
to continue forward with a research
project using bioinformatics so once you
have completed your registration please
share
on the chat box the link to your profile
and i will explain briefly
what you can do with this profile okay
so i will show you my profile
okay once you log in you can click right
here and you will find your profile
open up and so
if you want to share your profile and
just go right here to the url on top
copy this url and you can share this
right here
with everyone in the chat box so please
let me know i'll give it a few minutes
so that
at least a few of you will be able to
complete your profile and share with us
for those of you that already have an
account
thank you aransa for those of you that
already have an account especially the
campus ambassadors that are here in this
session
please share your accounts as well
so we will take some account that is
complete so that we can show how a
completed profile looks
okay thank you
all right great so let's take just one
of these accounts as an example
here we have an account by subrajeet who
is already an expert
how do we know that he is an expert
he is an expert first of all because of
the activity that we can already see on
his profile so you can see that all of
your activity as you go through the
lessons as you try different projects as
you try different analysis techniques
are quantified and what that means is
that you get a number of points for
completing each step and that
immediately signals to the mentor
community that you have accomplished the
basic training and you're ready to get
started with your research project so
the way the research fellowship works is
it starts from this basic training
what is covered in the basic training so
importantly i think in today's world
when we speak about bioinformatics the
major focus is on big data
this big data comes in the form of
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics there are many different
types of omics and ultimately you have
to know how to process each individual
types of data and then integrate them
together to really have this systems
level view of what's happening in a
biological condition and so we've
designed these so that you have an
introduction and i will show you a
couple of courses that you can start
with for free so that you get into this
whole field of omics data
then you go through this basic training
and then you get into introduced to the
data science curriculum in r and python
so i will briefly show you a couple
examples and this is just to get you
started
so again as you can see this profile it
is complete with activity i can see
which courses super gene has completed
and i can also see that he has earned
certificates and those certificates are
going to stay with you unless the course
has been updated and when it's updated
your certificate will be
taken away so that you can complete the
remaining lessons and then get the
certificate back and that way we know
that you're staying up to date on some
of these important topics
in addition to that you can participate
in programs and today we're speaking
about the research fellowship program
but also we have many others that are
led by mentors who are experts in the
field and you will also be able to
develop a project so as we go through
one of the requirements that this
program has is so that you complete your
basic training now where would you start
your basic training
here on the courses tab right here in
the menu you can find a lot of courses
that as you work through some of the
material will get a personalized
suggestion for your profile so you can
see that for me i have some suggestions
on single cell transcriptomics machine
learning ebola virus etc and that's
because of my interests
but here below i have a list of
recommended and highly
active courses as well as some of the as
well as some of the
collections of courses that you can find
right here and one of the collections is
called getting started so i can just
click right here on getting started
and see what's included
the course that we recommend for all of
you to start with is a course called
bytes and molecules
the course
explains many of the basic terms
bytes
so
a lot of the basic terms that you need
to know to get into this field and it is
using you know language that anyone can
understand both
with and without
the kind of bioinformatics background
and it covers important topics that you
will want to understand before you
really get into a lot of the material
that is related to research using
bioinformatics so that's just where you
would want to start with
so after you complete
enough material to generate 10 000
points what will be made available
is right here
under projects you will be able to start
a new project and that is essentially
what this program is all about so this
program is going to be
focused on getting beyond the training
after you've completed the 10 000 points
and into a research topic now one of the
immediate challenges with that is how do
you process this huge amount of data
that oftentimes is beyond several
gigabytes or even terabytes of data that
you have to download on your computer
and so for that we specifically designed
a big data analysis platform that will
cover many of the typical processing
steps that reduce the amount of data
from gigabytes and terabytes to just
megabytes which is possible to analyze
either on your system or in the cloud
and we will introduce you to cloud
technologies using this platform called
the t violin for platform developed at
the caliber bioinformatics research
center at university of haifa as well as
some of the cloud technologies offered
by other companies like google co-lab
github and other resources that are
going to be useful for you to leverage
as you develop your career in
bioinformatics
so here we have i'll just briefly show
you one example as you probably all know
transcriptomic data data on rna
sequencing is becoming more and more
prominent in many different areas of
research including oncology
neuroscience and other fields and
briefly you can appreciate the
simplicity of this platform because it
really organizes the information in a
logical step-by-step process and by the
way this is reflected in the coursework
that you will find on the learn portal
it also guides you using artificial
intelligence based on the data that you
upload and the information that you
would like to receive from this pipeline
so that you can eliminate the common
mistakes that people make when they try
to design these
workflows on their own
now as a result of running these
workflows you also get a clear sense of
the logic behind the analysis including
the inputs and outputs of different
methods and so once you're ready to
transition to your own independent
pipeline that you want to build on your
own now you at least understand the
logic why would i use this method and
not that method when would i try to
modify this setting or that setting and
this spans as i mentioned across many
different areas of analysis including
next generation sequencing data mass
spectroscopy
structural biology as well as many
methods for data integration and
modeling machine learning and other
types of applications so all of you can
definitely go through some of these
resources the thing is once you've
created an account on the onixler
omixlogic portal you automatically get
access to the demo level on this
bioinformatics platform after 24 hours
so from the moment that you created a
profile today tomorrow morning you can
already start using this platform seeing
how it is used in different courses and
projects that we will talk about
so this is the t binary platform
now ultimately you're probably wondering
well okay i have these resources i can
go through the training i can understand
what topic i would like to analyze it i
can perform the analysis but how do i
know that i'm doing the right thing
and so to do that we have a community of
mentors and i think that's a very
critical point to
briefly discuss
so our community of mentors first of all
is an international community many of
our
mentors come from research backgrounds
many of them have a phd
in a particular domain like
bioinformatics computational biology
neuroscience oncology etc and today you
will hear from some of them
but also many of them come with industry
experience and so for those of you that
understand what you want to do with your
career if you would like to go beyond
basic research and focus on
translational research projects that is
one of the
specific goals of this program as well
as a research fellow you get to explore
a variety of topics and select one that
is either relevant for industry or for
research and we'll talk about this today
including different collaborations that
we have with universities and
organizations that provide us with this
opportunity to know what is needed and
is in demand at the cutting edge of
basic research and industry r d as well
so what are some of the outcomes the
outcomes of this program is that you
will come out knowing
how to apply bioinformatics to a
particular project and you will be able
to complete that project within a short
period of time and just to give you a
sense of what i mean by that i want to
pass this presentation now to dr
harpreet kapoor